JAMES GRIME: One, two, three.
Test, test, test.
ROGER BOWLEY: If you're going
to do videos about numbers,
these are the ones you
would love to do.
JAMES CLEWETT: As far as the
computer's concerned, this
simply doesn't exist.
JAMES GRIME: Don't ask me
to say it, we could
be until next week.
RIA SYMONDS: 16's a very
special number to me.
It's my actual favorite
number.
JAMES GRIME: So this is called
a truncated icosahedron.
RIA SYMONDS: It's five sided.
It's a pentagon.
JAMES GRIME: Let's try it out.
I'm going to try and
play this as well.
You'll notice the difference.
GERARDO ADESSO: I just realized
that there is a
number that I see every day when
I enter my office, and
this number is 42.
JAMES GRIME: And, well, if you
need to go to the toilet, you
get up and you have to move
past all the other people.
MALE SPEAKER: I'm at the
southeast corner of England
today, and I'm talking to you
about a number with a bit of a
difference.
JAMES CLEWETT: It is an antique
1980s television.
[DRUMS]
[EXPLOSION]
[CHEERING]
ROGER BOWLEY: They get to
figgit, they get to 20 sheep,
and they couldn't
cope with that.
JAMES GRIME: Yeah, thanks
for pointing that out.
Thanks for bringing that up.
JAMES CLEWETT: And as a child,
I was fascinated by this.
Absolutely fascinated.
But it's taken me 15 years to
get to the point where I can
explain it to you.